while there have been countless male
horror villains the genre has also been
a great space for menacing female leads
whether they be young or old
supernatural or mentally deranged here
are some of the scariest female villains
who made us keep our lights on at night
the best parents always seem to provide
their children with a healthy amount of
love understanding and stability through
good times and bad sadly that is
certainly not the case for young carrie
white in the 1976 film adaptation of
stephen king's classic novel carrie the
movie focuses on the teen's tortured
existence and the endless cruelty she
suffers at her high school due in part
to her fanatically religious mother
margaret white puts the lord before
anything else especially her daughter
whose adolescent changes only exacerbate
the issue after being informed of
carrie's incident in the girl's showers
she proceeds to demean carrie both
verbally and physically in the most
disturbing act of all she locks carrie
in a makeshift prayer closet to pray
away her sin her cruelty only
intensifies as she attempts to stop
carrie from attending prom stating that
everyone will laugh at her the elder
white eventually meets her end when
after an attempted stabbing carries
snaps and assaults her with the help of
her telekinesis margaret is often
referred to as the true villain of
carrie and it's not an unfair assessment
carrie despite her now infamous actions
during the prom night scene truly is the
victim throughout most of the film one
of the most popular misconceptions in
all of pop culture is that jason
voorhees has always been the antagonist
in friday the 13th while jason is
synonymous with the series it was
actually his mother pamela holding the
knife in the series first outing the
first friday the 13th film especially
compared to later entries is noticeably
moodier and slower paced additionally
unlike later entries where jason was on
full display the film doesn't reveal the
killer's identity until the final scenes
betsy palmer infamously only took the
role because she needed the money to buy
a new car she even went as far as to
call the script quote a piece of sh and
hoped no one would see the film despite
those less than enthusiastic impressions
palmer doesn't phone in her performance
for even a second instead of simply
being a seemingly kind middle-aged woman
in a blue sweater palmer also manages to
bring genuine menace to the role she
perfectly plays a deranged mother
seeking vengeance on the crystal light
counselors after they failed to stop her
son from drowning
don't let her live
i want jason
i won't
palmer's performance is still highly
regarded within horror cinema and the
catalyst for the rest of the series her
gruesome demise at the film's climax
might have been the end for her
character but it opened the door for
jason to become the iconic killer in all
the films that followed
misery is still considered one of the
best adaptations of stephen king's work
and it's not hard to see why not only is
it impeccably directed by the great rob
reiner it also features one of kathy
bates greatest performances in the story
rider paul sheldon is injured in a car
accident and saved by annie wilkes she
initially comes off as a kind if not
mildly eccentric woman annie introduces
herself to paul as an extremely
enthusiastic fan of his book series
which centers on a character named
misery but as the days go on annie
enraged at paul killing off misery
reveals her psychotic tendencies
you
dirty bird
how could you
she can't be dead
this leads to annie both mentally and
physically abusing paul as she forces
him to rewrite the book annie's
perfectionist demands and overbearing
meddling disrupts paul's creative
process and the two head towards a
deadly finale the concept of the
psychotic fan is a disturbing recurring
trope that has basis in real life it's a
common occurrence for celebrities of
varying types to be harassed by overly
obsessed fans of their work bates
portrays that mentality with ample gusto
balancing both manic cheerfulness and
bloodthirsty rage it was no surprise
when at the subsequent 63rd academy
awards bates took home an oscar for
actress in a leading role
stephen king definitely has a knack for
creating memorable female antagonists
and rose the hat is no exception dr
sleep the sequel to the shining picks up
30 years after danny torrance
experienced the horrors of the overlook
hotel as dany copes with both his
sobriety and his shining ability a new
threat looms it's revealed that people
with the shining have become victims to
a vampiric cult known as the true knot
the cult led by rose the hat maintains
immortality by consuming the essence of
shining users the film centers on dany's
fight to protect a young girl named abra
and her gift from rose despite being the
leader of a vicious group of vampiric
monsters rose is not a one-note villain
she legitimately cares for her clan and
is heartbroken when one of their
immortalities finally expires however
the film never lets you forget just how
cruel and sadistic rose actually is at
her core the most horrific example being
a scene when rose and true not kill a
young boy for his essence she explains
that the essence grows stale as people
age which is why her clan targets
children rebecca ferguson received much
praise for her portrayal of rose the hat
injecting the role with equal parts
malice and charisma
behind every psychotic serial killing
doll there is an equally psychotic
serial killing woman in the case of
charles lee ray also known as chucky
that would be tiffany valentine who was
first introduced and bride of chucky
retroactively created as chucky's
equally bloodthirsty girlfriend tiffany
succeeds at resurrecting him after his
gruesome demise in child's play 3. what
begins as a joyous if not bloody reunion
quickly goes south as chucky reveals his
dismissive feelings towards tiffany this
results in serious relationship issues
as chucky electrocutes tiffany in her
own bathtub then as a spiteful act he
utilizes the series recurring voodoo
curse to trap tiffany's soul in another
doll the plastic duo then tricks a young
couple jesse and jade into transporting
them to new jersey along the way chucky
and tiffany spill a fair amount of blood
and rekindle their undoubtedly twisted
but endearing romance sadly the
honeymoon doesn't last long and chucky
starts to severely criticize tiffany's
domestic skills
what would martha stewart say martha
stewart
tiffany was so well received by child's
play fans that she was brought back for
three additional sequels
beware the stare of mary shaw she had no
children only dolls and if you see her
in your dreams be sure you never ever
scream whether it's billy from saw or
annabelle from the conjuring director
james wan clearly has a fascination with
dolls and puppets but the precedent for
this recurring trend in his work was set
back in his third theatrical release
dead silence the film follows jamie
ashton who after the death of his wife
returns to his hometown for answers
answers concerning a mysterious
ventriloquist doll and the infamous
local legend about a woman known as mary
shaw she was a renowned ventriloquist
who didn't take kindly to a rude child
interrupting her act and saying that he
could see her lips move
who said
i did i can see it her lips are moving
when the child mysteriously goes missing
the townspeople hunt mary down and kill
her however mary's final wish was
fittingly to be turned into a dummy and
buried with her dolls now in a new
ghostly form complete with soulless eyes
and ventriloquist doll mouth she seeks
vengeance on jaime's bloodline
throughout mary's long reign of terror
she leaves a disgusting trademark on her
victims she rips their tongues out and
gives them horrific puppet-like scars on
their faces
now
who's the dummy
the loved ones is often regarded as an
underrated gem from the past 15 years of
horror cinema the film centers around a
high schooler named brent who ends up in
the crosshairs of his demented classmate
lola after declining her offer to go to
prom brent still coping with his
father's death is kidnapped by her he's
then forced into a disturbing mock prom
by lola and her father while he's
mentally and physically tortured lola
played by robin mclevey completely
steals the show her performance rides
the fine line between disturbing and
campy but never once does mick levy go
too over the top lola at no point in the
film sees anything wrong with what she's
doing to brent she just views the
situation in her demented mind as the
perfect prom night with the cutest guy
in school this delusion is aided by her
equally insane and uncomfortably close
father who helps her with this sickening
act the scale of lola and her father's
crimes only increases throughout the
film which takes several bizarre twists
and turns the true terror of lola is
that throughout the entire movie she
could do anything at any moment she goes
from playfully trying to feed brent in
one scene to threatening to horrifically
mutilate him in the next it's a
performance and film that deserves far
more attention
orphan has received a lot of praise and
criticism since it was first released in
2009. however the one thing all viewers
can agree on is that the character of
esther played by isabelle fuhrman is
completely shocking unique and
unforgettable at the beginning of the
film kate and john coleman hope to heal
their strained marriage by adopting a
third child they're both immediately
drawn to a young russian girl named
esther and decide to adopt her things
almost immediately turn sinister as
esther becomes increasingly manipulative
and injures a school bully as her
transgressions evolve she begins to
reveal her true sadistic nature her evil
goal is to remove her adopted mother
entirely from the picture kate
eventually discovers that esther has no
documented records and a lot of people
in her history have ended up six feet
under all of that information however is
upstaged by the big twist that esther
has a rare hormone condition and is
actually a mentally deranged 33 year old
woman
stop talking to me like i'm a child
after the film's original release furman
received accolades for her disturbing
portrayal of esther her performance was
so haunting that fermen with the help of
some special effects will reprise the
role in an upcoming prequel to the film
jordan peel's us has been hailed as one
of the most thoughtful and original
horror films in recent years it's the
story of the wilson family and a
vacation that goes horribly wrong the
mother adelaide portrayed by lupita
nyong'o is on edge almost immediately
due to a childhood trauma that occurred
in the area when she was walking through
a hall of mirrors at a local carnival
she was attacked by a doppelganger of
herself called a tether many years later
that memory has taken on a dangerous new
reality a group of tethers which seem to
be a version of her entire family start
to wreak havoc at the command of their
mother a woman named red a dangerous
duplicate of adelaide red quickly makes
her intentions clear as she regales the
terrified wilsons with a horrific
monologue whenever on screen red speaks
in a haunting and almost withered voice
which only serves to heighten her menace
add to that her thousand-yard stare
physical prowess and unstoppable drive
and it's impossible to not be frightened
by her it's eventually revealed that
adelaide herself is the actual tether
having snatched and swapped places with
her double during their childhood
encounter nyong'o's double performance
truly is an impressive feat and it's
still disappointing to many fans that
she wasn't nominated for an oscar
one of the best characters in rob
zombie's firefly trilogy is baby played
by sherry moon zombie a member of the
disturbing backwoods serial killer cult
gang known as the fireflies flanked by
the likes of otis and captain spalding
it's quite impressive that baby stands
out as the craziest first introduced in
house of 1000 corpses baby is a
hollywood obsessed and overly bubbly
serial killer carrying out all of her
family's heinous deeds with a sense of
glee and a smile on her face moon zombie
has a clear appreciation and
understanding of the role having played
it three times from 2003 to 2019. over
the course of the following films the
devil's rejects and three from hell
baby's insanity would only increase
despite her bloodthirsty and cruel
nature baby still maintains a strangely
enduring charm a recurring theme in rob
zombie's work this is best illustrated
by a delightful scene where baby and
spalding pester otis into stopping for
ice cream baby despite being a
blood-crazed psychopath does seem to
have a lot of affection and appreciation
for her entire criminally insane family
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
horror films are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]